and now now to present the Music Awards
we have a man who was born backstage in
a Chicago thin the first sound he heard
was a 30-piece pit band and at 13 months
he was on stage with his mother and
brother doing the black bottom at 3 he
was tap dancing by the time he was four
he was doing a single and so tonight at
the age of 26 we bring you that grand
old man of musical comedy who from birth
has known what the score is mr. Donald
O'Connor
thank you very much is the nicest Ward
I've ever had thank you
heavy
carried away now then gentlemen I would
like to present those nominated for the
best scoring of a musical picture and
they are Alice in Wonderland 12 Disney
Productions RKO radio Oliver Wallace an
American in Paris and Emma hello an
American in Paris metro-goldwyn-mayer
Johnny green and so Chaplin the great
Caruso metro-goldwyn-mayer Peter Hermann
Adler and Johnny green again on the
Riviera 20 Century Fox Alfred Newman and
showboat metro-goldwyn-mayer Adolph
Deutsch and Conrad Salinger the envelope
please
thank you let's pool
the winners are jana green and saul
chapel
Johnny Green has relinquished - that's
on the orc
zone steam at the moment
and he proudly accompanies so Chaplin on
stage for the awards the scoring of an
American in Paris the first nomination
for Saul Kaplan Johnny won an award in
1948 for Easter Parade that's oh yes
so all Chaplin I thank you very much I'm
not gonna let him get away with it we
couldn't have done it without Sully
obviously the greatest voice was that of
Johnny green now Donald O'Connor goes
back to the podium and also to continue
ladies and gentlemen you're still with
us aren't you those nominated for the
best scoring of a dramatic or comedy
picture and they are David and Bathsheba
20th Century Fox Alfred Newman Death of
a Salesman the Stanley Kramer company
Columbia Alex North a place in the Sun
Caramon Frank's friends excuse me
friends Waxman Quo Vadis
metro-goldwyn-mayer Nicholas Rosa and a
streetcar named desire Charles K Feldman
Group productions Warner Brothers Alex
North that's part of the group I'm sorry
the envelope please I love doing the
winner is Franz Waxman for placing five
mr. Waxman
walk down
pictures the place in the Sun mr. waxman
received an award for Sunset Boulevard
in 1915 seven previous nominations he's
the founder of the Los Angeles music
thank you very much I'm deeply grateful
for the honor thank you
these winners are really most profound
movie well we got a lot more here now
where was that
oh here we go now those nominated for
the best songs are in the cool cool cool
of the evening from here comes the groom
and paramon music by hoagy carmichael
and lyrics by Johnny Mercer a kiss to
build a dream on from the strip about
Kefauver put those all the way but
they're still here metro-goldwyn-mayer
lyrics in music by Bert Kalmar Harry
Ruby and oscar hammerstein ii never from
golden girls from the 20th Century Fox
music by Lionel Newman and lyrics by
Eliot Daniel too late now from Royal
Wedding metro-goldwyn-mayer music by
Burton Lane and lyrics by alan jay
lerner and wonder why from rich young
and pretty metro-goldwyn-mayer music by
Nicholas Brodsky and lyrics by Sammy
Khan may I thank you sir the winners are
Hoagy Carmichael and Johnny Mercer the
cool
for bogey from a girl in John
the spotlight is picking them up and
here they come
all together they're all noted
compulsions Hoagy buttermilk sky
Stardust Johnny Mercer got the award in
1946 for on the Atchison Topeka in the
Santa Fe and you'll see now just who is
going to speak first Mercer has his
Oscar Carmichael has you then they're
voted tonight on behalf of Johnny this
wonderful collaborator
I want to thank Bing and Janie and all
the people in the music department of
paramount for the wonderful way that the
song was presented it includes the
producer - I know and it was a thrill to
see it performed in the picture and
things like that that make songs and I
know we're both very thankful and I'm
very proud to be holding this believe me
because I was runner-up to this fellow
once before he's a great writer sale
word same the same goes for little sir
echo little sir echo be Johnny Mercer
took it oh he took it and held on I mean
the Oscar as well as the microphone they
made a mistake I think on the program as
I remember former presentations the name
is Hugo
I thought it was coming back to tell me
how well I sang the song
I'm gonna let Crosby speak for himself
from now on